>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, D.C.
>> Kenneth Nylrady:
Good afternoon.
My name is Kenneth Nylrady.
I'm a reference specialist in
the Library's European Division,
and on behalf of the European
Division and our Chief,
Grant Harris, I'd
like to welcome you
to the Library of Congress.
The European Division is one
of four area studies divisions
in the Library, and
is responsible
for recommending materials
and reference for most
of the countries of Europe,
except Great Britain,
and Ireland, Spain, and
Portugal, and European part
of Turkey, which is
covered by other divisions.
Highlighted today is
the Russian collection,
which numbers some
1.6 million items,
whether in Russian
or about Russia.
Our speaker today has
made very good use
of our rich Russian collections.
Judge Stephen Williams practiced
law in New York City at the firm
of Debevoise Plimpton, and as
an assistant U.S. attorney.
And then taught law
at the University
of Colorado Law School from 1969
to 1986, with visiting years
at UCLA, Southern Methodist
University, and the University
of Chicago, where he was also
a fellow in law and economics.
He was appointed to the
U.S. Court of Appeals
for D.C. Circuit in 1986.
Besides his current book,
he is also the author
of "Liberal Reform in an
Illiberal Regime: The Creation
of Private Property in
Russia, 1906-1915," published
by Hoover Institution
Press in 2006.
Today, he will be speaking
about his current book,
a biography of Vasily
Maklakov, "The Reformer:
How One Liberal Fought to
Preempt The Russian Revolution,"
published by Encounter
Books in 2017,
available at fine book
stores everywhere.
I am pleased and honored to
introduce to you Judge Williams.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephen F. Williams: Well,
first, I want to thank both Ken
and the Library of Congress.
I think it's true as to
both of them, without --
I couldn't have written
the book, possibly.
The Library of Congress
has a fine collection
of the Duma Records, which
were the principal things
that I used here, but the Duma
Records are obscurely arranged
in the sense that the spines
do not clearly indicate what is
inside the spines.
So very often, I would find
myself groping for what it was
that I wanted, and Ken very
often came to the rescue
and managed to fish out from
the shelves what I needed.
So I'm extremely grateful
personally to him,
and also to the Library
of Congress.
And also to Peter Roudik,
who I can see there,
although since the klieg
light is in my eyes,
I can't see him very well.
But -- excuse me?
>> It's not loud enough.
>> Stephen F. Williams:
It's not loud enough?
I was concerned with that.
Now?
>> The silver one
is the speaker.
>> Stephen F. Williams: The
silver one is the speaker?
What's this here for?
>> This is for the --
>> Stephen F. Williams: Okay.
This one has a green light.
Okay, but this one counts?
>> That one counts.
>> Can we turn this up some?
>> Just wait and see --
>> Stephen F. Williams:
Can you hear?
>> Say something again.
>> Stephen F. Williams:
Say something again.
>> Let me turn this one.
Go ahead. Can we test it?
Can you test it?
>> Stephen F. Williams: Yes.
Yes. Can you hear?
>> Oh, that's better.
>> That's --
>> Stephen F. Williams:
That's good?
Okay. Okay.
So, at any rate, I am
very grateful to them
and both the institution
at the Library of Congress
for making my research,
and obviously many other
people's research, possible.
Today, I want to
do three things.
One is to talk of Maklakov
himself personally,
so you develop, I hope,
some appreciation for him --
which, working on it
for 10 years, I did.
I came to feel he was a friend.
And the second thing is
to look at the problems
that anyone trying to promote
the rule of law in Russia
in the critical period, 1905
to 1907 -- critical for me,
critical for Maklakov, because
that was when he was most active
in it -- to promote the rule of
law, the obstacles they faced.
And finally, I want
to close with a note
on just a particular snippet
of a debate that he had
where his primary adversary
was Alexander Kerensky,
because I think it shows
a kind of elegant way
in which a speaker
in an adversarial relationship
can deal with a demagogic bully,
if I may use that term.
So first, Maklakov --
it is harder to see
here than I thought.
I may hold my notes to
get them closer to me.
He's born in 1869, and
his father combined sort
of three capacities in his work.
He was a scientist,
an ophthalmologist
who published research
in ophthalmology.
He was also a clinical
physician, and in addition,
he was a manager,
somewhat indirectly.
Because he worked at the Moscow
Eye Clinic, which still exists,
and is still an eye clinic.
It's a handsome building
in Moscow.
And there were, in what appears
to have been a quite
typical czarist arrangement,
three layers of management above
him, but the actual holders
of those positions did
not do any management.
They were there because
they were aristocrats,
and they needed to
be taken care of.
So they were given
positions in the hierarchy
of the institution, leaving
the actual work of management
to people below that level,
including Alexei
Maklakov, my man's father.
His mother -- his mother
was very well-educated,
spoke four languages, and
she was very religious.
And I emphasize the
religion because --
first place, Maklakov writing
about her emphasizes it,
and the second place, it's
reasonably clear that in Russia
of that era, if you're a
highly-educated intellectual
person, religiosity is not the
first thing that comes to mind.
So that -- the Maklakov
household brought together two
different intellectual
strains in what appears
to have been harmony and love.
And I think helped set
the threshold for Maklakov
as someone who can deal
with people who disagree
on very fundamental issues in
as harmonious a way as people
who disagree on fundamental
issues can.
Incidentally, his mother died
shortly before he became 12.
In due course, his
father remarried.
His stepmother is not the
-- as you would expect,
there's not quite
the devotion to her
as there was to his mother.
But I think she -- Maklakov's
father was already very
well-connected, both
intellectually and politically,
and I think the -- his --
the stepmother, Alexei
Maklakov's second wife,
brought him in touch
with more and more
of the intellectual elite.
So these were around all the
time of Maklakov's later youth.
His time at the university
-- first, at the university,
his reputation for
eloquence was established.
There had been a --
there was famine in 1891,
and there was a practice
in the university
of a student orchestra having
a concert, the proceeds
of which were normally given
to help impoverished students
at the university get along.
But at the time of this
famine, the idea came forward
that it would be good to
devote the proceeds that year
to famine relief, but
not everyone agreed.
There was a large meeting in
a large hall, with students.
There was students
gathered on one side
of the room advocating
the traditional treatment
of the proceeds -- on the
other side of the room,
advocating famine relief.
They sort of proceeded alternate
sides, and then Maklakov spoke
on the side of famine
relief, at which point,
the line for using it for the
traditional purpose faded away,
and the decision was
made to give it to --
to devote it to famine relief.
He was at risk in the university
of becoming a perpetual student.
He had three majors, a
couple of years at natural --
in natural sciences,
then a long period --
I think four, maybe even five
years in history, and finally,
he turned to law, and he got his
law degree in less than a year.
Why did he leave history?
I think natural science
wasn't really that good a fit,
but why did he leave history,
in which he was doing
extremely well?
Well, he had a tendency to
get into scrapes, and --
actually, this had happened
when he was at the gymnasium,
but they were less
consequential.
It was more consequential
at the university level.
What were these scrapes?
They were their involvement in
demonstrations, none of which,
as far as I can make out,
involved any violence.
But it was also true
that Maklakov's approach,
at least sometimes in
these demonstrations,
was distinctly in-your-face.
So there's a period --
a point in one of them
at which some authority figure
is trying to get the students
to clear out of a
space, and Maklakov says,
"We won't disperse until
you clear out the police."
That did not go over well.
The person representing
authority said, "Grab him,"
and he was grabbed, and --
so that brought that
episode to an end.
Partly as a result of
this and similar episodes,
a guy named Bogolubov, who
was a high-ranking character
in the university, later
actually became Minister
of Education, was heard
to say, "So long as I'm
at this university, Maklakov
will not become a professor."
So that was naturally
daunting to Maklakov,
in terms of thinking
of his career,
even though he was
very strongly supported
by the most distinguished
history professor,
Paul Vinogradoff, who
later went to Oxford.
And in fact, Vinogradoff
tried to talk him
out of being disswayed [sic]
by this remark of Bogolubov.
But Maklakov, wisely, I think,
and probably for other reasons,
switched out of history
into law.
Besides this remark
of Bogolubov,
which obviously put a chill
on his history career,
he received for these activities
something called a wolf's
passport, which was
not actually a passport
to anything except
possibly oblivion.
It meant, essentially, you
were barred from the university
until this passport
should be revoked,
and there was no
particular procedure
for getting it revoked.
So it was the end of an
intellectual career, really,
or at least potentially, it was.
Now, I'd mentioned
that Maklakov's father was very
well connected, and he was.
And he managed to get this
reversed, but it did mean
that there was a period
when Maklakov was at risk
of essentially having his
career blighted for what,
in the long run of things,
seems no good reason at all.
At this point, I want to
introduce my Maklakov's brother.
My Maklakov is Vasily.
The brother who's interesting
and important is Nikolai.
They have the same
family background,
and Nikolai turns
out, in many respects,
to be the virtual opposite.
At this period when my
Maklakov is, at every stage,
resisting government
arbitrariness,
his brother Nikolai is staging
government arbitrariness.
And the most sort of
intense development
of this is the Beilis trial.
The Beilis trial, sometimes
called Russia's Dreyfus trial,
involved a Jew who had
the unfortunate fact
of being Jewish, and being
located in the vague,
general vicinity of a
place where the corpse
of a child who'd been
brutally murdered was found.
And the other thing that
was hard luck for Beilis was
that some anti-Semites in
the area had the bright idea
that this was an occasion --
this should be used to have
a trial for blood libel,
an accusation that Beilis --
first that Beilis had done this,
and that it was all part of a
Jewish project to produce blood
for somewhat mysterious
Jewish rituals.
So this trial proceeded,
stage-managed
by Nikolai Maklakov,
with Vasily Maklakov --
I think it's fair to say
the lead defense attorney.
I do want to quote the remark
of a juror who was questioned
by a reporter after the case.
"Karabchevsky, we
didn't understand.
Gruzenberg, we didn't trust.
Maklakov hit the
nail on the head."
So it sounds as if his
argument was quite pivotal
in the acquittal of Beilis.
So Nikolai, meanwhile, was not
only generally stage-managing
this, but doing extremely
fishy things,
of which the clearest example
is eavesdropping on the jury.
Although, as someone pointed
out, it must've been sort
of depressing, because people
on the jury kept remarking,
"There doesn't seem to be
any relevant evidence,"
which was true.
There wasn't.
So the question is, why are
these two brothers brought
up in the same household
so different?
And my theory, entirely
speculative,
is that Vasily Maklakov was
often and seriously the target
of regime arbitrariness,
and he responded to that,
as almost anyone might, with
a deep hostility to that sort
of thing, and a determination
to fight it.
Of course, he fought it
on behalf of other people.
While so far, it appears
Nikolai had no such experience.
So, if you have a rebellious
child, take consolation.
You may be breeding a great
champion of the rule of law.
The -- a word about his friends.
I want to leave time for
other important things.
The most important one
there, really, is Tolstoy.
He first saw Tolstoy quite
by accident, when he was sent
because of an epidemic
-- not an epidemic.
That overstates it.
A rash of diphtheria into
the house of friends,
and incidentally,
the father/husband
in this house was the model for
Stiva Oblonsky in Anna Karenina.
Anyway, so he's sent
as a child there.
He sees this old man
with a long, white beard
and wearing a smock, and he asks
the mother/wife figure there,
"What is this?"
And she says, "Well, that's
the great writer Leo Tolstoy.
It's all right for
a writer to go --
a great writer like him to
go around dressed like that.
But for ordinary people,
it's not suitable."
So that -- he learned
that lesson.
He participated with Tolstoy
in actually delivering relief
in the famine of
1891, and after that,
Tolstoy developed the practice
of calling upon Maklakov to go
for walks with him in
the city of Moscow.
And Maklakov was sufficiently
self-conscious about this
to ask himself, "Why does
great writer ask a callow youth
like me to do this?"
And his answer was based on
something that Tolstoy had said
about the way he moved around
at his estate, Yasnaya Polyana.
He didn't go by horse,
or at least typically
didn't go by horse or foot.
He went by bicycle, and he went
by bicycle, Tolstoy explained,
because bicycling through
the ruts and avoiding stones
and so forth kept his mind
occupied and prevented him
from serious thinking.
Serious thinking,
he wanted to avoid,
because it would be tiring, tire
his sort of key brain cells.
So the urban equivalent of that
was to have Maklakov along,
diverting him, but not
challenging his thinking
in any serious way.
Tolstoy also made
referrals to Maklakov
of cases involving
religious eccentrics, who,
as you can understand, quite
naturally went to Tolstoy.
And these gave Maklakov
experience --
first place, seeing a side of
life that he had no exposure to.
He's a -- almost an -- I mean,
I think it's fair to say,
a different world from
sophisticated, urban Moscow,
and also gave him
experience trying cases
to juries in that environment.
And he came away not only, it
appears, with a great ability
to handle juries, but a
great respect for them.
And I think that
played out in his view
of politics more generally.
Did this relationship have any
effect on Maklakov's character?
It seems to me, one can argue
both ways, but I would suggest
that his finding, that you could
have a deep relationship --
and I think, on Maklakov's
side, clearly one effectively
of love -- for someone who
disagreed fundamentally
on issues of political
economy, for example --
you could do that, and
there was no problem at all.
And that that partly accounts
for Maklakov being the very
gregarious person that he was,
and during the times
of political conflict,
talking to people on every
side, a very healthy thing.
Another friend is
Alexandra Kollontai,
who at the relevant
period, is sort of migrating
from Menshevism to Bolshevism.
Not exactly Maklakov's ideology,
not that at all, but a --
not merely a close
friend, a lover,
and someone with whom
he got along very well.
And even -- I mean, her letters
to him show her identifying
speeches that he made
with which she finds very
impressive, and so forth.
But they were both
mavericks in their parties.
He did not really belong in
the Constitutional Democrats,
for reasons I may or may
not have time to go into,
but he definitely
didn't belong there.
She didn't really belong
with the Bolsheviks.
At one point, she told an
Italian communist, "If you hear
that I've been arrested
for stealing the silverware
in The Kremlin, just chalk it
up to my disagreeing with Lenin
on some issue of rural
policy," which --
so she was very realistic
about her party.
Let me turn now to the -- in a
way, I'm going to try to turn
around the approach
I took in the book.
The approach I took in the book
was recounting Maklakov's work
in various projects and --
throughout the period
1905 to 1917, what he did,
how he did it, and so forth.
Now I'm going to turn that
around and view it as a roadmap
for the challenges confronting
anyone interested in creating
or enhancing the rule
of law in this period.
So at this point, the -- it's
a more analytical approach
than a sort of historical
approach.
How do these things fit into the
development of the rule of law?
First, I want to say that I
think if there was ever a time
when the rule of
law had a chance --
had a chance for
making progress,
this period 1905 to 1917 is it.
The first part of that
period, you have four Dumas.
They're the only period when
you have a legislative body
in Russia.
To be sure, the first two
Dumas were very radical.
The last two Dumas
were very conservative.
So that was not necessarily
a program for reform.
Neither of them was
a program reform,
because the radicals took on the
administration very vehemently,
provoking the administration --
the regime to be more hostile.
But at least it was a period
when there was an institution
for discussion of
Russia's legal problems.
So it was an opportunity
of that sort,
and a somewhat representative
legal institution, the Duma.
And in this period,
the bureaucracy was
distinctly divided.
There were reformist
elements in it,
and highly reactionary
elements in it.
The Czar, I think it's fair
to say, was reactionary,
but it was also very wobbly,
a virtue in an extremely
reactionary person, so that --
you know, looking at the
broad scene, you might say,
"They could've done
something useful."
But they didn't.
And then there's the period
of the provisional government,
where the liberals, in
principle, take charge.
They are in charge of the
provisional government.
They have all kinds of
obstacles, to be sure,
but if the rule of law
is to be supported,
that seems like a good
opportunity for it.
So the -- what I'm going to
do is to divide obstacles
to the rule of law into
two types, and I'll try
to match them up in all cases --
formal institutional
defects, and informal lacks.
The formal institutional
defects are, for example,
impediments to judicial
independence.
The informal ones are
the social attitudes
that underlie everything.
They underlie both the
capacity to adopt reforms,
and the ability, once a
reform has been adopted,
for it to take root and generate
the real sort of protection
that we'd like to see
from the rule of law.
And so I should say that the --
of course, the purpose
of the rule of law,
the primary purpose, is
to protect the people
from state arbitrariness.
At least, I think that's
the definition I will use,
so we'll have to accept
it for this afternoon.
So I'm going to try to
go quickly through these.
Yeah. But as I say,
in each case,
I'll match the institutional
problem with a sort
of social attitude problem.
First, let's take
judicial independence.
Nominally, that had
been established in 1864
with the protection of judges
against being kicked out,
or demoted, or transferred,
but the person who was Minister
of Justice during most of
this period testified later
that he had the ability to
bend judges to his will.
His word, "bend," and I
think it's fair to say
that he was not understating
his powers.
And presumably, judges
got the message.
I've never been able to figure
out exactly what his techniques
were, just as, I have to say,
dealing with current Russian
judges, who I think it's fair
to say exemplify
the same problem --
how it is that they tend to
succumb to regime pressure.
But there is regime pressure,
and it is successfully exerted.
And what about the
relevant social attitudes?
In the elite, let's take
Tolstoy, perhaps the most --
indeed, the most extremely
example, but still --
but not that far
off from his fellow,
highly intellectual, colleagues.
He took seriously the Biblical
injunction, "Judge not,
that ye be not judged,"
and taking that view,
and also the view that
all state exercise
of power was illegitimate,
and equally illegitimate,
he wasn't interested in
nuances of the difference
between an independent court
and a submissive court.
So he was no friend at all.
And the -- no friend
at all on this issue.
He was a good friend
as a person.
And the others of the literary
elite, although perhaps not
as extreme as Tolstoy,
shared this sort
of at least indifference
to the kind of protections
that Maklakov and
anyone interested
in the rule of law would be.
What about the peasants?
They had a number of aphorisms
stating their view of law.
One of which, for example, is,
"If all the laws were removed,
people would live justly."
Well, that doesn't seem like
a good foundation on which
to build a rule of law state.
So, again -- I mean, this is
sort of a very strong case,
I think, of an institutional
defect --
a formal institutional defect
and a strong social attitude
defect for anyone trying
to build the rule of law.
Second, remedies for
official lawlessness.
It's really quite
a similar story.
There were all kinds
of gaps in the system.
It's -- I can't find
specific attitudinal --
or, evidence of specific
attitudinal differences,
but I think it's part of the
passivity that people notice
in Russians of that
era, perhaps other eras.
I think can be chalked up to --
because it relates to the fact
that there aren't remedies.
There's nothing you can do.
Third, centralization
of state authority.
I won't go into it, but the --
again, we turn to Alexander II,
and we have a creation
of institutions
of local self-government, which
are valuable and important.
But they're -- above
all, they're subject
to discretionary review by the
Ministry of Internal Affairs.
And so the people in those
institutions are accustomed not
to making local legislative
decisions within a framework
of law, but making local
legislative decisions
within a framework
of discretionary
review from on high.
That seems to me
quite different,
as kind of training
for the rule of law.
Now, property rights.
One could go on and on about
property rights, and of course,
perhaps I did in my first book.
But on -- if we're talking
about land and other property,
apart from the peasant -- what
the peasants had, I think it --
you know, it was recognized.
So that subject to what I said
about the lack of independence
of judges, and about
the gaps in remedies
against lawless official action,
there was protection
for property.
When you get to the peasant
level, I'll simplify quickly
to say that, until
the Stolypin reforms,
you have essentially
limits on your --
a family's lot size was subject
to reduction depending
upon the --
or perhaps it'll be increased
depending upon essentially the
number of workers in each
family on the commune.
And the ability to cultivate
the land was circumscribed
by the need for coordinating
with all the other people,
because of the tiny lot size.
And the Stolypin reforms, though
I think they're important,
barely scratched
the surface in that.
Attitudes, the attitude
aspect of property.
Contrast the west, where private
property's generally recognized
as a bulwark against
the centralized state.
There was no such
parallel in Russia.
Property, instead of
representing independence,
because it gives the holder
a sufficiency, as it were --
property there represented an
extreme form of dependence,
because the richest -- all
of the regular landowners
who had serfs, at least until
1861, were highly dependent
on the Czar for keeping
the serfs in their place.
So it symbolized
dependence, not independence,
and it symbolized dependence of
a particularly oppressive kind,
dependence enabling the
dependent people the better
to oppress their serfs.
Then the peasants, I think,
only word needs to be said
about their view of property --
they had been property
until 1861.
That is not a very
good background
for having a high
respect for it.
I want to -- I'm going
to flip through a number
of things quite quickly.
Let me -- I'll resume my
regular notes on this issue.
The direct government efforts to
prevent private associations --
you know, the Biblical --
or, the saying of Jesus,
"Whenever two or three
are gathered together
in my name, I am there."
I think one can impute to
the czarist regime a parallel
but radically different slogan.
"Whenever two or three
are gathered together,
and my minions are not there,
they're probably up to no good,
and therefore, it's a good idea
to prohibit private
associations."
Maklakov encountered this
at a fairly early stage,
because the -- as I said, the
student orchestra funds were
to be allocated to
peasant relief.
Well, how was that
to be administered?
The watchful eye of the state
kept an eye on how that was
to happen, so that Maklakov
and the other students couldn't
just use their own entity.
It had to be something
approved by the state.
And actually, they worked out
a compromise that made it look
as if the students were
not being subservient
to the government, but in
fact, they sort of were.
Maklakov was active on all
these issues, including the ones
that I've omitted
because of time.
But the upshot was something
where, it seems to me,
is beautifully summarized by
Tocqueville in a description
of pre-Revolutionary France.
"When the Revolution happened,
one would have to search most
of France in vain for 10 men
who had the habit of acting
in common in an orderly
way, and taking care
of their own defense themselves.
Only the central power was
supposed to take care of it."
And I would argue that Russia
had created a similar --
the Russian regime had
created a similar situation.
I want to turn to -- yeah,
I think I should turn,
at this point, but I would
welcome questions later.
I want to turn to this debate
between Kerensky and Maklakov.
The issue is turning into
a statute a decree enacted
in October 1906, which
released various bonds
on the peasant estate.
And, as Maklakov said in
introducing the measure --
he was the reporter
for the committee
which was in charge of it.
It was a bill initially
supported by the government,
incidentally, some sign
of actual reformers
at work in the government.
He acknowledged that, first
place, the bill itself --
the Decree of 1906
was itself limited.
The bill which he was
offering was somewhat limited,
in the sense that it did
not make radical changes
with the 1906 Decree, and he
had a very clearly stated reason
for that.
If they -- he believed that
if they stuck within the sort
of general parameters
of the bill,
essentially removing
restrictions
on the peasant estate, it
would probably get approval
at the state council, and
would become a true statute.
There were others who
wanted to take the occasion
to remove restrictions --
similarly arbitrary restrictions
on Jews, and Maklakov would've
been delighted to do that.
But he said, and
argued very firmly,
that this would defeat
the whole project.
So anyway, Kerensky basically
acknowledges that the Decree
of 1906 was good, that
the bill extending it,
even if only modestly, was good,
but he wanted to do two things.
He wanted to trash
Stolypin, who was the creator
of the 1906 Decree,
and by extension,
since Maklakov was
promoting essentially a decree
of Stolypin, by innuendo,
he trashed Maklakov.
And Maklakov responded to
this with great moderation
and discretion, and I just want
to read to you what he says
in response to the accusation
that he's being some
way soft on Stolypin.
"For me to recognize when
my opponent is right --
" that was Stolypin --
"to recognize the desserts
of my political foe is a duty
of political honor, and I
have here fulfilled it."
And that seemed to be --
to very nicely put paid
to the Kerensky attack
on Maklakov.
There are other things
I can go into on that,
but I think I should stop.
So I'd be delighted
to have questions.
>> Thank you for that.
>> Stephen F. Williams: Eric?
>> So he had legal training.
In the Revolutionary
Movements of 1905 and 1917,
and just more generally, his
theory of law and the rule
of law -- how did
he come to reconcile
that with those Revolutionary
Moments?
And -- I mean, there
were debates in them,
and we have jurists about
principles of natural law
versus positive law, and whether
the Revolution was compatible
with that, and whether -- I
mean, there were other thinkers
in the Kadets who said,
"Well, we promote rule of law,
but revolution can be part of
that if we embrace principles
of natural rights, and
thereby impose natural right
into the legal system.
And thereby, reconcile
all of these things."
Did he have sort of a
philosophy of natural right?
>> Stephen F. Williams:
If I can,
I'll try to take a
two-tracked approach to that.
One is, part of what
you're saying sounds
in very high legal
theory, and on the whole,
I would say that Maklakov
tended to avoid that.
Now, one area where perhaps
you would say he didn't was
on the question of coups
d'état, coup d'états,
whatever the plural is,
where his position was
a quite practical one.
That is to say, how
does it all work out?
He acknowledges that they're
illegal when they happen,
but sometimes -- and he points,
for example, to the coming
to power of Catherine the
Great -- they work out well.
And they become accepted by
the society, and that's it.
You've just got to move on.
He did not think that that was
true of a coups of November --
of June 3, 1907, the coup
by which the Czar
changed the franchise
for the election of the Duma.
That's why we go from the
radical first two Dumas
to the conservative
third and fourth Dumas.
So he did not accept that as
a coup that got legitimized.
Then, as to the -- I think it's
fair to say that in the truly --
well, in the February
revolution,
where the Czar's regime
-- where the Czar --
where Czar Nicholas was
compelled, effectively,
to abdicate, he pretty
strongly believed
that the liberals taking power
should do everything they could
to make his brother
Michael the Czar.
Which was actually what
Nicholas tried to bring about,
while all the others
except for Milyukov tried
to discourage that, I think
because they felt it would get
in the way of their
exercise of power.
And also, I think
they had no sense --
and this goes back to the sort
of cultural attitude
toward institutions.
They had no sense of the
advantage of having a framework
for reaching decisions.
The Duma had a very narrow
franchise starting in June 1907.
So the Duma that was
around in February 1917 was,
in certain respects,
illegitimate and
unrepresentative.
There were actually
ways in which
that could've been changed,
because there was a practice
in other institutions
of bringing back
into the current
institution former members
of the institution.
So the Duma -- the fourth Duma
could've added back in people
from the first, second,
and third,
and thus made it a more
representative institution.
As far as I can make out,
the liberals spent no time
at all thinking about
this option,
and I can only attribute it
to an indifference to sort
of institutional
continuation, and normalcy,
and balance of powers.
Somewhere in my notes, I have
a favorite quotation of mine,
which is Maklakov quoting the
poet Nekrasov, "It isn't easy
to correct the work
of centuries."
And I think the liberals, saving
Maklakov and a few others,
had very little sense of that.
Yes?
>> Lena Lebocek [assumed
spelling], Russian linguist.
Could you tell us, how and
where did you find documents
and records, if it
was in Russian?
How you learned old
Russian [inaudible]?
>> Stephen F. Williams: Oh.
The Russian writing?
>> Yes.
>> Stephen F. Williams: I
find that very difficult,
but the printer --
the happily --
the Russian printing that I was
looking at was almost always
in the 20th century,
and overwhelmingly
in the Duma records, which
are really pretty clear.
And I can't remember
whether they had --
to what extent the typography
is a little -- it certainly --
it's slightly different
from current typography,
but not radically.
So that was not a serious
problem, which is not to say
that I was able to read
it easily or fluently.
But I was able to
work through it.
As for the handwriting
of Russians,
I'm completely at sea in that.
I was told at an early
stage in this venture
that Maklakov's handwriting
was absolutely indecipherable.
That's by people who read
Russian handwriting all
the time.
So I never even tried.
And in fact, I didn't come
across letters out from him,
which would've been
helpful, anyway.
There's a great cache
of letters in to him,
some of them Alexandra
Kollontai, some of them also
from another girlfriend of his,
which gives an interesting
picture of his life,
including his romantic life.
Yeah? That's fine.
>> So what was his relationship
with the Octobrists like?
I've been reading
recently about an attempt
by the Trubetskoy
brothers to create a party
of peaceful renewal between
the Kadets and the Octobrists,
and as far as I can tell,
they got basically themselves
and a couple of cousins
to join, but nobody else.
But, I mean --
>> Stephen F. Williams: I mean,
that's a really good question.
>> So was he actively trying
to maybe create some sort
of coalition of right --
>> Stephen F. Williams: He was.
He was a great believer in
coalitions, and the chapter
on national liberals
talks a lot about that.
There was extraordinary
stubbornness.
I mean, he had been a
Constitutional Democrat
from its founding congress.
He was active in that founding
congress, but he was at odds
with them on a number of
very important issues,
the most important being
actually the question
of peasant property.
But the other thing
is that, in --
particularly in the third
Duma and the fourth Duma,
the Constitutional
Democrats were very reluctant
to form alliances
with other parties.
And particularly --
Milyukov had the idea,
which I find slightly crazy,
that the three keys --
the three important things
to address were the scope
of the franchise, removal
of the state council
as a coordinate part of the
legislature, and establishment
of a rule that the government
must be responsible to the Duma.
And so -- called them the three
locks, and seemed to believe
that until they could
be unlocked,
no progress could be made.
And there's an interesting --
sort of a debate in the Kadet
party, where they go from a kind
of extreme formulation
by Milyukov,
which seems to make cooperation
with other parties a very
low order of priority,
to a slight change on
the basis of people
like Maklakov seeking
more compromise,
and more affiliation
with other parties.
But the change in the language
is miniscule, I have to say.
So the obduracy of the
Kadet party and the --
and particularly of
Milyukov was extreme.
On that, I should add something.
In 1917, the era of the
provisional government,
question of agricultural
reform is again before them.
Maklakov comes up
with a proposal
which would not involve
any sort of upsetting
of the then-prevailing
property regime,
but it would favor
smallholders by making --
by providing differential
tax rates,
with higher taxes on
the larger tracts.
So since the principal concern
of the Kadets was
distributional,
favoring the poor
peasants at the expense
of large landholders, it seemed
to fit their purposes
quite well.
They wouldn't listen --
well, they listened to him.
He gave a speech, and they said
almost by acclamation, "Well,
that's not our policy.
There's no point in
us discussing that."
They did not attack
it on the merits.
They just said, "This isn't
the way we view things."
And it's true.
I mean, they had been arguing
for something much more drastic
for more than a decade.
And they weren't about
to listen to proposals
which would accomplish a great
deal of what they really wanted
without the disruptive effects,
which were in the middle
of World War I -- would've
had very serious consequences.
And see, I wanted
to say another thing
about institutional
continuation.
Although addressing the war
would've been very difficult
under any circumstances, because
there basically was a great
social divide in Russia on that.
I do think that a
legislative body, expanded,
as I've suggested,
to be more liberal
than the fourth Duma was,
would've provided a forum
for debating that,
which might've led
to an agreed-on policy.
I mean, in the end, it
went by default to Lenin,
who had a policy which, in the
end, if it was not a majority
that agreed on it,
at least those
who disagreed were ineffective
in taking any other --
in bringing about
any other view.
And in many respects, it seems
to me one could say Lenin
was right, but the --
it would've been far better, I
think, and possibly achievable,
to arrive at a conclusion,
whatever it was,
by debate among interested
parties.
Rather than by, as happened
in October, a coup d'état,
although one of the easier coup
d'états that ever happened.
Yes?
>> Were there foreign thinkers
or constitutions that engaged
in some way that they --
>> Stephen F. Williams:
That's interesting.
That's a wonderful question,
because there's one event
that inspired great
ridicule on his part.
There was a conference between
Milyukov and Count Witte
in late 1905, when
things are shakiest.
And Milyukov says, "What the
Czar should do is promulgate
a constitution.
He should take either
the Belgian
or the Bulgarian Constitution,
translate it, and promulgate it
as Russia's Constitution,"
without any thought
of slight differences that might
exist between, first place,
a vast empire, and second place,
a country encrusted with --
I don't want to use
the term backward,
but with social expectations
radically different from those
which underlie a
constitutional regime.
And Maklakov has
great fun with that.
I think it's fair to say
he might be criticized
for not paying enough attention
to foreign possibilities.
He was an admirer of the
British Constitution,
for reasons that I think you can
see, that fit into his notions
of gradualism and -- well,
certainly gradualism.
He never mentions the
American founding.
In fact, he speaks quite
scoffingly [sic] of the idea
of people getting
together in a room
and concocting a constitution.
I mean, I happen to think
they did an awfully good job,
and maybe that's because
I'm paid to enforce it.
But anyway, he never
seriously addressed that.
And switching to his side, I
think he was probably right
to think that the constituent
assembly, which was, in fact,
elected, of course,
at the end of 1917 --
it's hard to say what
they would've done
if the Bolsheviks had let them
try in creating a constitution.
Because the kind of deficits in
social thought that I've tried
to outline would've been
a very serious obstacle
to making headway on that.
Yes?
>> I think you started by saying
something about you wanted
to show how someone could stand
up to a party, or to a bully.
I forget -- how did you put it?
>> Stephen F. Williams: Oh, yes.
>> But how did -- what
would your conclusion be?
>> Stephen F. Williams:
Oh, no, that was --
that was the episode
that I reported --
well, there are other
aspects of that debate,
in terms
of the Maklakov/Kerensky
challenge in 1916.
But let me tell you more
about Kerensky's bullying.
>> Do speak into the micro --
>> Stephen F. Williams:
Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Let me tell you more about
Kerensky's bullying technique.
First place, there was
constant misrepresentation
of what Maklakov had said, and
just goes on, and on, and on.
Second place, there
was this innuendo,
that since this decree
came from Stolypin,
and Maklakov is working
within the framework of trying
to improve that decree, as well
as turning it into a statute,
Maklakov is therefore, in some
way, tainted with all the sins
that the liberals generally
attributed to Stolypin.
And -- I mean, I think the
-- I find it dishonest,
bullying in the sense of
going -- charging on and on,
even in the face of mild
correction by Maklakov,
and not a way in which people
who are seriously wishing
to advance the argument
would debate.
But Maklakov really
never picks up --
never responds by
mirroring those techniques.
Quite the opposite.
He responds possibly by even
being more inclined to a sort
of cool, analytical view,
and a non-accusatory
view than he normally is.
Although, you see,
those are attributes
of his debating style
all the time,
so maybe it's not
that much different.
But he's not blown into echoing
the misbehavior, by my lights,
and I think definitely
his lights, of Kerensky.
I have to say that I'm probably
the only person in the field
of Russian history
who's read that debate,
and I feel it gave me to --
an exposure to Kerensky that I
would never want to have again.
And that gives me a perspective
on Kerensky that scholars
of the period would
all benefit from.
I tried to share
that in the book.
>> One more question.
>> Just a quick question.
I know that your
book ends with 1917,
but how did he fare
after the Revolution?
>> Stephen F. Williams:
The book actually goes on.
There's a chapter
called "Exile."
So we have actually 40 years
covered in less than 20 pages,
and he was named
Ambassador to France
by the provisional government.
In October, he heads
off to France,
but before he can present his
credentials at the Quai d'Orsay,
the provisional government
has fallen,
and the Bolsheviks
are in charge.
So he's left there without
credentials, essentially,
or without working credentials.
Now, France didn't recognize
the Bolshevik regime until 1924,
so there's a seven-year
gap during
which Maklakov essentially
occupied the Russian Embassy
in Paris, and carried
on responsibilities
as best he could.
The responsibilities fell
into a variety of forms.
In the very first period,
it was trying to make sure
that some Russian
voice was heard
at the Paris Peace Conference,
and I think he did
as well as one could.
But the people at the Paris
Peace Conference were just not
that interested in what
defrocked Russians,
as it were, might have to say.
They also weren't interested in
what the Bolsheviks had to say,
because they were very
doubtful whether the Bolsheviks
would survive.
So that was one project
where I think he tried
as well as he possibly could.
The other great activity really
was being a Russian voice
in Paris, a channel between
the émigré community
and the French government.
And I should say, the French
government, to its credit,
actually created an office
to which it appointed him,
to be this representative from
the Russians to themselves,
and he had to do such things
as -- when a -- let's see.
There was a -- I'm
trying to remember.
There were two assassinations,
and one was by a --
I think it's a Pole in Poland,
and he's arrested and is sent
to a military tribunal.
When the Russians hear that --
Russians in Paris hear that,
they think, ugh, that's
the end for this poor guy.
And the assassination was
one they were generally
sympathetic to.
So they were -- did
not like the idea
of this person getting a quick
brush-off at a military trial.
In fact, it turned out that the
Poles had selected this means,
because they could control it.
Not a model of the
rule of law, perhaps.
They could control
it, and make sure
that nothing drastic happened
to this guy, and actually,
Maklakov, through
an intermediary,
learned what was up, and was
able to pacify the Russians.
So he was doing that
sort of thing.
And the other thing he
had to do a great deal was
to help Russians get
their papers out of the --
out of the Russia -- out
of the French bureaucracy,
and as I point out in the
book, Maklakov is recognized
in a novel published in France
in, I think, 2015 as someone
who has helped one
of the characters
of the novel get
admission to France.
And so his cast shadow going
forward about 100 years.
>> Thank you.
>> Stephen F. Williams:
Thank you.
Whoops.
[ Applause ]
>> Thanks for coming.
That was --
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.